Jack I wanted you to draw me like one of
your french girls oh yeah kate winslet
definitely knows what it's like to
disrobe when in front of the camera
every Titanic fan knows that but Kate
gets to turn the tables in her new movie
because she's the one watching the liam
hemsworth chef his clothes you could be
married in this suit snapped up by some
eligible spinster or Haag trousers off
too
yes well I was standing in my underwear
um so anytime he's standing in your
underwear in front of a whole bunch of
people you don't know that well it's a
little awkward it was awkward for Liam
who's having to stand there in just his
underpants
I mean staring at Liam Hemsworth barely
clothed no that's not difficult actually
I think we quite like shooting that
scene yeah yeah I think her Aunt Judy
had had a much better time than I did
Judy and I actually found it very hard
keeping a straight face poor Liam you
know we'd return to look at sort of half
naked Liam and we just kind of go sorry
it's not you it's not it's us okay so
with it we're gonna do that again
Liam strips down to his skivvies in the
dressmaker a film about a fashionista
who transforms a rural community with
her couture creations who is that
stunning Miley's guy confessed he was a
little stressed over getting up close
and personal with Oscar winner Kate whom
he first saw on screen a Titanic at the
age of seven before any film I do I get
really nervous about it um start
questioning everything he wasted here I
think we should run away together Kate
and I have have some quite intimate
scenes in his film and after the first
day of shooting with her I felt at ease
one treat after another and one surprise
after another and one laugh after
another
you